In the previous video, you sawus getting ready for this year.
Cleaning everything, installing the office, setting up tents...
Because, people are arriving to help out,
with the next season of Project Kamp.
So, here weare: new year, new projects, new people,
new leaves, new flowers, same old sweater!
In this video, I'mgoing to show you all the things
we're going to do this year.
And, we're going to start offwith our construction projects.
Let me show you!
So, on the land, we have the small ruin,
which -last year - we renovated.
So, we added the roof on top, insulation,
made it into a dry space...
Built a veranda outside...
Because, the goal is to build a guest house in here.
But, actually, for the coming season,
we don't really need that yet...
So, we're goingto use it for something else!
Let me show you!
So, this year, we're going to use this space as anoffice.
So, we can do very productive work,
insulated from the heat, and the cold.
I cannot go further,because no shoes
are allowed after this point...
So, this is a good office...
We're going to keep itfor that.
One thing we still want to do here, this year,
is this box here, which is still unfinished...
So, as you can see: raw floor, insulation material...
Because, this is going to be the shower,
and thetoilet, for the future guest house.
And, we're gonna renovate that this year...
So, that's on the to-dolist.
And, something else for this ruin is outside..
So, here we are in the bottom of the ruin
It's abit older building, made from old granite rocks.
Currently used as a storage...
I want to renovatethis room this year.
But, we noticed in the winter that this wall was getting
completely wet, and madethe floor wet...
So, we need to fix that, before we're going to renovate it.
But, yeah, there are two roomsunderneath the ruin.
And, this year, we want to make sure they're waterproof
and cleaned up, so we can usethem.
So, that was all the renovations we're going to do for the ruin.
It's almost there already, so, we just need to wrap it up...
And, next, let me show you the other
renovation project we're goingto do...
Which is involving a shipping container.
So, here we have a beautiful, new, old,
rustyshipping container...
We got another one this winter...
They're very good, if you want a quick, temporary,dry structure...
So, we already have two shippingcontainers,
and this one is going to be storage.
So, there we're going to put all things, like bulk food
for the kitchen, seasonal tents, some garden tools...
And, we're going to build a big roof on top!
Thebiggest roof we have so far in Project Kamp!
So, we can also store other things,
like our materialstorage on the outside.
This is going to be one big container!
So, currently, we all live in vans and tents in Basekamp,
which is a pretty good setup.
And, we also have this old, yellow post office van,
which we're going to renovate this year.
Because, it's been here two years...
It's got afew leaks, a bit rough inside...
So, we're gonna clean it all up, and build a
nice proper space in there, so visitors can stay.
And, yeah, like, all of us live in vans and tents.
And, it's cool, butit's very temporary!
So, this year, for the first time:
we're going to build our Level 2 house!
Thefirst one.
And, let me explain what that means...
So, these are what we call Level 1 houses.
This, and also, vans...
Temporary structures that you put somewhere...
You can take them down.
For mostly to stay in the season,
and not really in the winter...
It doesn't require any legal paperwork...
Youjust plop them there, and you can stay in it.
So, yeah, Level 1 houses, we have a lot of that.
But now, we're going for a Level 2 house.
So, a Level 2 house doesn't exist yet,
but just toillustrate what it could look like...
Something like a shipping container...
Not even as complex as thisone,
but really just a container, that you put on a piece of land...
And then, you can live in it, whichgives more comfort,
than something like a van, or a tent...
But, it's not as complex as legalizingan entire new house...
So, that's what we consider a Level 2 house.
This sort of in-betweenstate,
that is still temporary, but gives you more comfort.
And, just while we're at it, let me alsoexplain you
what we think is a Level 3 house...
So, a Level 3 house would be more somethinglike this!
It requires a bit of imagination, but the principle would be
a proper house, built withheavy stones.
Legalized in the paperwork, where someone can
really live properly all year round.
We're not there yet, but in the future, for sure,
we would have these kind of houses as well here inthe project.
And, that's what we consider a Level 3 house.
A small disclaimer.
The things, Level1, 2, and 3 house, we made them up...
It's just for ourselves internally, that we know how to build,
and develop each type of housing.
But, for now, no Level 3 house yet...
We're going to start this year,
withour first Level 2 house.
Which is probably going to be built on a trailer.
A big trailer, with the size ofa shipping container.
Not sure yet, if it's going to be shipping container house...
Anyway, our next renovationproject is gonna be our big ruin.
So, here we are in the big ruin,
or what we callour Community Center.
We're a bit behind with this project...
We hoped we would do more, but most ofthe last year,
we spent on designing.
So, just to give you an imagination, what it's going to be like...
This building is going to be the kitchen,
where you can do big shared meals for the community.
In thisarea, here is going to be more like toilets and shower,
where the people can clean up.
And, over here, the big space is going to be a shared community space.
So, when it's hot outside or cold and rainy,
you can be in here sheltered.
And, we would also have a few offices,
where people can do digitalwork.
So, online with the help of some others,
we started making the drawings of this building.
But, the next step is actually to look into the legalization of it...
Because, we want to keep asmuch of the existing structure as possible.
Which is, obviously, not really the usual thing to do...
And, so, we're not sure how much is possible...
We need to look into the fire regulations...
And, there's a bitof an urgency here...
Because, the local rules and regulations change every 10 years.
And, this is theyear they're going to change, and they might change a lot,
because there was a fire here a few yearsago.
So, yeah, we're in the middle of that process...
You can follow it on the research module,
but it'sstill a bit in the boring process of legalization...
So, those were the construction projects...
Andnext, let me show you our landscaping projects.
And, this category is a bit overwhelming
Because, if you have 10 hectares of land,
there's so much to do...
You can grow your own food...
Planta forest...
Make swales, retain the water...
So, it's important to prioritize.
And, last year, it became pretty clear to us,
what should be our first priority.
It's a bit lame, but kindof essential...
It's to make sure we're more fire resilient,
because the land burned down, afew years ago.
The region always burns down...
So, especially in the summer, it's kind of important tobe fire resilient...
Because, otherwise, the whole operation just wipes down in an afternoon...
So, that's kind of where we based our landscape goals upon...
And, one of the main things we'regoing to do,
is to clear more of the native trees.
Which, we've done for instance here...
There used tobe a lot of bushes around.
Then, we cleared it up so the native trees can grow.
And, they are abit more fire resilient than the other ones.
But, there's still a lot to do...
And, so, as you cansee, this is what it usually looks like.
Just a lot of bushes and vegetation...
Which, is usuallya good thing, but here especially,
on our rocky hill area, it's bordering the neighbors' land.
Which has an eucalyptus farm, so,
it's the highest risk of fire up here!
So, we want to make sure,that this area is a bit more fire resilient.
So, our next project is this lake right here.
I guess, I should watch my words...
According to the YouTube comments,
this is a swamp, or a pond, but not alake...
Makes sense, but it's pretty cool!
It's for animals, where they can drink,
and for us, to havea bit of a water reservoir.
However, it needs a bit of clearing up,
because the soil around it iseroding...
And, we also want to make it bigger...
The main reason for that is so we have a bigger waterreservoir.
So, in case of a fire, or a very dry summer,
we can retain more water, as a backup.
Theneighbors actually also told us that there used to be helicopters here,
when there's a fire to takethe water.
Which they currently can't do, because it's fully overgrown...
So, if we clean it up a bit, theycould.
So, yeah, we want to revitalize this water reservoir.
Also to make sure the water from the landflows in here...
It retains as a healthy place for the animals to come...
We could actually use somehelp here, from someone
that has more expertise in building lakes, swamps, ponds...
Whatever you wantto call this...
If you want to come, and help out, let us know!
Sign up on the website!
So we can makethis into a nice, little, thriving ecosystem.
So, sorry YouTube...
This year, we're still not going to grow our own food.
We just don't have the capacity yet,
but one thing we do want to do, is plant more fruit trees.
Wealready did this a bit here and there..
But, this year, we really want to plant between a 50 and100...
Mainly because it's more of a long-term investment,
to grow our own foods.
That in manyyears from now, we can pick the fruits.
So, yeah, planting fruit trees this year.
Another thing, wewant to do this year, is cleaning the creek.
We actually already wanted to do this last year, and we started.
but it became a bit more work than planned so we were not able to finish it
But, the principle would be: we have this creek flowing on the land...
And, we want to make sureto remove all the invasive species there.
And, keep the native trees, so they can really grow,
and flourish, and create a healthy place.
So, here we are at the waterfall,
which isflowing right there...
Water going down, and this is the lagoon we cleaned up last year.
It's now in the winter, so it filled up with water, which is really cool!
But, it's actually notthat deep...
It looks like a lot of water, but it's only this deep...
And, there's just thisthick layer of leaves, soil, earth in there...
So, this year, we want to clean it us,
so it's anicer place to swim.
But also, just so we have a bigger water capacity storage here.
And thesoil that we're going to take out is very good,
but we're going to put it aroundthis area.
So, the things can grow more there,
and we can store more water in here...
So, it's going to be a big muddy job in here!
And, besides all of the landscaping work,
wealso have a few upgrades we need to make to Basekamp...
One of them is a roof here, because now,
ifit rains and the door is open, it always gets wet...
The pans, it's not nice...
And, it's also when the sunshines,
it's very hot, when you're cooking...
So, we're going to make a little roof there.
And, besides that, this year we also want to be with more people.
So, last year we were at a maximum of 15.
This year, we'regoing for 25,
which means we also need to upgrade a few systems.
So, for instance, how we do dishwashing...
It's a bit messy where you store the plates...
So, we're going to upgrade that as well, so,
we havea few Basekamp improvements we have to make...
Which means, we also need to upgrade our toilet...
Now, this toilet is still the exact same one,
as how we originally built it!
We even have this littlesign, that says you need
to add some sawdust after pooping, from cardboard!
Still alive, stillthere!
Everything else got moldy, except this thing...
So, the toilet itself is kind of okay...
It doesn'treally need upgrades, but we just need another toilet...
Because, we're going to be more people...
So, in the morning, when it's busy,
some people have a high needency to go.
We just need a secondtoilet,
so we're going to build that.
And, probably, this time different,
where we separate the urinefrom the poop.
And, finally, here we are...
Back in the office, because we're gonna
have a few thingsdifferent for the coming year...
A few positions open...
One, is that there can be a Web Developerin-house here,
so we can improve our software to share our documentation.
And, also, a position for aCommunication Manager,
that helps us to distribute our messages in the world.
And finally, we alsoupgraded our video team!
Before, we had Javi, and now we also have Guilherme here.
And, I think I justpronounced his name wrong -- it's a difficult name...
But, uh, we can call him Guy!
- Hi YouTube!
Their goal is to get the YouTube subscribers to 1.000.000 this year!
And, that's a hundred thousand, so we have some work to do...
They're now editing the video for next week,
which is going to be aboutthe pickup.
If you already want to see that, make sure to support on Patreon.
Or not, and you'll seeit next week, here on YouTube!
It's gonna be cool!